I should forgot my line if there was
ever any doubt that final fantasy is one
of the biggest names in gaming that
would have been well and truly over
written by the success that 15 has had
in its first week of life Square Enix
has announced that Final Fantasy 15
shipped five million copies worldwide
across ps4 and xbox one since its launch
in November 29 that seems to suggest an
awful lot of you are out there
role-playing as characters with better
hair than any of us will ever have a
Japanese press release translated by
Siliconera revealed that the five
million figure includes digital sales
and makes 15 the fastest selling entry
in the series to date Final Fantasy 15
is also the first in the series to
launch globally on the same day and
clearly that's working out pretty damn
well earlier this year game director
Hajime Tabata said Final Fantasy 15
needs to sell 10 million copies to be a
success later clarifying that the 10
million figure is the studio's goal not
the amount required to turn a profit in
the greatest news of all time in the
history of everything that has ever
existed across all conceivable realities
Rainbow six siege is getting a year to
of content through 2017 earlier this
week the u2 season pass appeared on
playstation 4 xbox one and steam and
outline a similar amount of content to
that available in year one you too will
include four new maps that are free for
everyone eight new operators and new
primary and secondary weapons if you
grab the season pass you'll get access
to the new operators a week early when
they're at least as well as a
five-percent renowned boost a rainbow
six carbon charm to rejoin your favorite
operators weapon ash obviously 8
exclusive headgear and uniform
customization and a bunch of other cool
dude stuff ubisoft of also outlined
where we'll be hunting TS over the next
12 months the four seasons will focus on
operators and maps from Spain Hong Kong
Poland and South Korea the release
schedule appears to follow a similar
schedule to you one with the first
season beginning in February 2017 at
each consecutive season following every
three months if you want to get into the
game and I highly recommend you do you
can grab the gold edition which includes
the base game and the year 2 season pass
on ps4 and PC right now and xbox one on
december six or if you're so inclined
the complete edition includes all of
that and immediate access to all you
want operators and is available on PC
right now with Xbox one to follow next
week and ps4 at an answer
25 date it appears the effects of the
global Pokemon go hype trainer still
lingering since Pokemon Sun and Moon are
some of the fastest and best selling
games of all time anywhere this week
Nintendo of America announced that not
only with Sun and Moon the most
pre-ordered games in history they are
now the fastest selling games the
company has ever launched in the
Americas in under two weeks sales have
already eclipse 3.7 million units that's
an eighty-five percent increase as
compared with the previous record
holders pokemon X&Y over a similar
period of time Sun and Moon are also
Nintendo's most successful game launches
ever in the UK and in Australia Pokemon
Sun has remained the number one selling
game on any platform for the past two
weeks before the time being pokemon X&Y
remain the best-selling 3ds games ever
with 15.6 4 million units sold as of
September 30 this year you may remember
from earlier this year when a research
group estimated that 2.6 million
PlayStation VI units would be in homes
by the end of the year they've since
decided that it's less like way way less
like imagine a number that's lower than
that number it's less turns out the cool
old be its bulky and pricey new addition
to gaming tech isn't quite the surefire
hit it with cracked up to be at least
not yet research group super data have
not their estimate down significantly
now reporting that they expect less than
750,000 PSP our units to be sold this
year yep that's almost 2 million less
than the original guesstimate super data
has also updated its sales expectations
for other VR headsets like Google's
daydream which is down to 261,000 from
450,000 estimates for HTC vive at 450 k
oculus rift at 335 cakes and gear VR
heading the pack at 2.3 million have
remained the same not to put too fine a
point on it super data concluded by
saying the VR market will be the quote
biggest loser of holiday 2016 when it
comes to gaming placing the blame on
supply inconsistencies and a lack of
marketing
did no man's sky make you no man's cry
well this week hello games released a
huge patch that at a bunch of new
features called the foundation update so
you might want to give that a no man's
try why you like this here is a list of
things that are new new game modes
normal creative which like to explore
without limits and survival which is a
more challenging endurance experience
base building you can create an outpost
using modular structures and decorations
farming system the ability to purchase
freighters for resource transfers new
biomes and resource types visual changes
like motion blur and temple
anti-aliasing a new UI a photo murder
ps4 formations for Space Flight more
blue skies Les Brown terrain improves
grass color selection improved lighting
onset grass improve transparency and
blending for distant grass and about a
thousand other things this week on site
you can go and check out our Final
Fantasy 15 review and all the other
stuff about Final Fantasy you can also
check out gamespot universe and the game
spot now app that is now available on
iOS thanks for sticking with us for
another week be sure to have yourself a
lovely weekend and we're gonna go inside
cuz it's really hard
[Music]